être correspondant pour radio canada à
washington ça veut dire en fait être
correspondant pour l'ensemble des états
unis derrière moi il ya quarante et une
carte postale j'ai visité en cinq ans 40
et à la 41e bien sûr c'est pour le
district de columbia
je la montre imaginer le contraste entre
l'administration de barack obama en 2013
et l'administration de douane en juin
maintenant 2018 pays de contrastes des
choses absolument est un an que j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir premier voyage c'est
ok ok là où j'ai pu voir la pauvreté des
blancs qui habitent dans des maisons
mobiles en plein hiver le chauffage
était assez bas donc j'ai gardé mon
manteau le chauffage était bas
évidemment pour sauver de l'argent
parfois c'est difficile je monte
celle-là au 15 as parfois c'est
difficile de trouver des cartes postales
qui représente bien quelque chose que
les gens aiment
dans ce cas là vous voyez des centres de
détention des prisons cette ville là où
15 à celle est connu pour ses quatre
prisons l'appel président city et des
cartes postales des fois qui représente
très bien les sujets qu'on a couvert sa
c'était à ferguson au missouri donc
toutes ces revendications de noir devant
des policiers blancs c'était aussi un
peu l'image de mon voyage qui était une
tornade de production assez incroyable
donc un pays de contrastes je vous en
montre une autre new hampshire garder la
première fois où on a vu dans
l'antichambre en personne c'est en 2015
au début de sa campagne les services
secrets pas encore très nerveux ce qui
fait qu'on ne puisse approcher en
sortant le soutien peut nous en regarder
dans les yeux en disant ici ou une
studio externe on avait des contacts
comme ça qu'on ne peut plus avoir
maintenant avec le président l'arizona
ça c'était la frontière la première fois
donc c'est un pays qui absolument vaste
cette frontière qui est encore une fois
dans l'actualité parfois voyager ça veut
aussi dire qu'on en découvre un peu sur
les pays ses particularités
oui ce conseil sont énormément fier de
leur fromage en grains et pas aussi bon
que celui au québec peut-être parce que
eux le mange free quand même
il est très bon ça fait des belles
connaissances je vous dirais que c'est
ce que je retiens entre autres
énormément de gens rencontré des gens
très très sympathique
des gens avec qui je reprendrai des
conversations avec plaisir pour moi
prochaine étape c'est l'europe dès cet
automne donc je vous invite à m'envoyer
des commentaires des suggestions
lieux à visiter ou encore de reportages
à faire dans les prochaines années à
partir de paris à bientôt